dans l'échelle des valeurs
parthenay république la question
centrale du travail il n'y a pas de vie
épanouissant travail la responsabilité
des républicains sous l'impulsion de
nicolas sarkozy c'est de tout faire pour
que ceux qui veulent créer travailler
avancées puissent le faire librement
nous sommes ici aux républicains le
parti de la france qui veut travailler
qui veut avancer qui veut créer qui veut
progresser redonner confiance aux chefs
d'entreprise à ceux qui innovent qui
crée des emplois dans notre pays chiche
dans les entreprises note politique
économique doit être centré organisée
autour de l'entreprise la france de 2016
s'enfonce dans le chômage de masse avec
françois hollande avec quatre ans de
pouvoir socialiste
il ya aujourd'hui plus de 5 millions
sept cent mille chômeurs on voit bien
qu'avec la baisse des taux avec la
baisse du coût du pétrole
on avait toutes les cartes en main pour
y arriver la valeur travail a été érodée
elle a été méprisée par des politiques
socialistes complètement absurdes qui
ont découragé les pme et qui ont attaché
des boulets aux pieds de nos entreprises
la question c'est quel est l'objectif du
club du travail l'objectif du code du
travail pour moi n'est pas simplement
défendre ceux qui ont un travail mais de
faciliter l'entrée dans le travail de
tous ceux qui n'en n'ont pas un des
éléments du risque aujourd'hui quand on
est chef d'entreprise et quand on décide
d'embaucher c'est que tout se décide en
dehors de son entreprise
on va vous imposer des accords nationaux
va nous imposer des lois extrêmement
contraignantes qui font que finalement
là où vous pensiez pouvoir gérer
tranquillement un deux trois employés
que vous aviez embauché pour répondre
aux besoins des entreprises vous êtes
face à une situation où le jour où il ya
un retournement économique
eh bien vous êtes bloqués donc ce que
nous croyons nous c'est qu'il doit y
avoir une négociation au niveau de
l'entreprise
le lieu
naturelle normale efficace du dialogue
c'est l'entreprise c'est au niveau de
l'entreprise qui doit y avoir une
discussion entre le patron et les
employés sur qu'est-ce qu'on fait
combien de temps de travail
laissons la liberté aux entreprises de
france de choisir sortir des 35 heures
ou si les salariés le souhaitent de
rester aux 35 heures liberté évidemment
36 heures payées 36 37 heures payées 37
cela dans un cadre d'un accord collectif
il faut qu'on soit capable à l'assemblée
nationale de voter une vraie loi de
simplification du travail pas la loi
elle comrie qui en réalité ajoute de la
complication à la complication mais une
vraie loi de simplification pour donner
aux pme aux entreprises la possibilité
d'embaucher à nouveau de conquérir des
marchés pour que tous ceux qui veulent
travailler qui veulent créer qui veulent
avancer qui veulent progresser
puisse le faire librement en france je
rêve simplement que chacun de vos fils
ou de vos filles puissent se dire à 18
ans et à 20 ans j'ai pas besoin de
m'exiler pour réussir je pourrais
réussir ma vie en france
c'est en france que je veux monter
l'échelle sociale
c'est dans ma région dans mon terroir
dans mon village que je veux créer ma
vie oui
je prends le ballon oui je crois une
drôle vivant où chaque jeune pourrait se
dire oui moi aussi je peux réussir